genauso lang wie es glücksspiel gibt
gibt es auch personen die versuchen sich
ihren gewinn zu erst angefangen bei
einfachen kartentricks irgendwelchen
kabeln um automaten zu hacken oder das
fälschen von casino chips es gibt
unendlich viele möglichkeiten und es
wurde unendlich oft versucht abseits
aber vom einfachen scan gibt es auch
immer wieder ansätze das casino
auszutricksen ohne dabei regeln oder
gesetz zu brechen
genau das hat mich mega interessiert und
deshalb wollte ich wissen ist es möglich
im casino immer zu gewinnen
ziemlich eben nur um euch jetzt direkt
zu sagen dass es niemals eine
möglichkeit geben wir mit der 100
prozent gegen casino gewinnt und das
macht auch komplett in das casino
existiert eben einfach damit die
betreiber geld verdienen das ist wie
wenn justin t shirts verkaufen würde an
dem er fünf euro verlust machte das
würde der ziemlich schnell
wahrscheinlich wieder aus dem sortiment
rausnehmen
kasinos sind dafür da damit die
betreiber geld verdienen für nichts
anderes es geht dabei nicht um
chancengleichheit für spieler und es
geht darum dass die casinos geld finden
und falls irgendjemand doch irgendwann
eine möglichkeit finden sollte bei
irgendeinem spiel absolute überhand über
das casino zu haben könnt ihr euch
sicher sein dass dieses spiel nicht mehr
lange im casino vorhanden sein wird aber
worum genau drehen sich dann eigentlich
dieses video obwohl mir schon absolut
bewusst war dass es keine möglichkeit
gibt mit der man 100 prozent gegen ska
sino gewinnt habe ich mich gefragt ob es
nicht mathematisch möglich ist möglichst
nahe an die 100 prozent zu kommen und so
quasi das risiko zu minimieren
also habe ich google angeschmissen und
angefangen zu suchen die ersten sachen
nicht gefunden habe waren auch super
interessant aber nicht möglich für mich
umzusetzen in kurzer zeit zum beispiel
karten zählen im black jack hierbei geht
es mir im film 21 eindrucksvoll
demonstriert darum karten vorherzusagen
so funktioniert das system so dass man
das ganze spiel beobachtet und darauf
wartet bis nur noch einzelne karten aus
dem deck gespielt werden können da ein
kartenwerk immer aus derselben wertung
und anzahl von karten besteht kann man
zum ende hin ziemlich genau sagen welche
karten sich jetzt noch entdeckt befinden
und so hervor sagen welche karten man
zieht das system wurde 1961 von einem
us-amerikanischen mathematiker namens
android entwickelt und wird seitdem
benutzt die spielbanken haben natürlich
etwas dagegen und dann angefangen mehr
karten pakete zu benutzen die
kartenspiele nicht bis zum ende
auszuspielen
oder die leute einfach direkt aus ihrer
spielbank zu verwalten außerdem habe ich
jemanden gefunden der eine taktik namens
kessel gucken entwickelt hat bei dem er
den tisch so genau liest und guckt wo
der croupier den ball in den roulette
tisch reinwirft dass er vorhersagen kann
in was für einer spanne der ballon wird
okay schön und gut aber das sind alles
kleine sachen die ich jetzt auf die
schnelle lernen kann und vor allem kann
ich davon nichts im online casino
anwenden also habe ich weiter gesucht
und irgendwann bin ich
aufs martin galia system gestoßen
hierbei verdoppelt man seinen einsatz
immer wenn man verliert fängt man also
mit einem euro an würde man beim
verlieren 2 euro setzen müssen wenn man
dann wieder verliert 4 euro dann acht
dann 16 dann 32 und so weiter
sobald man dann wieder eine runde
gewinnt hat man seinen einsatz
verdoppelt hört sich erstmal gar nicht
so schlecht abend vielleicht ist euch
aber schon aufgefallen dass dadurch die
einsätze immer exponentiell steigen das
bedeutet bei 15 fehlversuchen müsste man
16.000 384 euro setzen um einen euro
wieder zurück zu bekommen dabei darf man
aber auch nicht vergessen dass die 14
versuche zuvor auch schon 16.000 383
euro gekostet haben also insgesamt werde
man irgendwo bei über 32.000 euro um 15
versuche zu machen also habe ich
angefangen hin und her zu rechnen und
habe eine sicherheit von 755 euro
eingezahlt damit kann ich meinem start
betrag von 1 euro und exponentielle
steigerungen bei verlust neun versuche
machen das ergibt im roulette wenn man
immer auf dieselbe farbe tipp bei neun
versuchen eine wahrscheinlichkeit von
0,1 75 prozent sein geld zu verlieren
oder in anderen worten eine
wahrscheinlichkeit von 99,8 25 prozent
sein geld mit neun versuchen wieder zu
gewinnen selbst das ist eine zahl bei
der ich niemandem raten würde das jemals
zu machen aber ich mache das für euch
damit ihr das nicht machen müsst habe
diese knapp 1000 euro eingezahlt und
dann angefangen zu zocken
das hier nicht sehen
es geht los ich könnte jetzt das
experiment beenden und ich hätte bloß
gemacht wir müssen aber natürlich weiter
spuren wir haben angefangen mit 755
dollar jetzt nehme ich mir 48 stunden
zeit um zu wir dabei auf und so gegen
dann das große zocken los und ich muss
ehrlich sagen es war komplett langweilig
ich habe mich halt komplett an diese
strategie gehalten und das bedeutet ich
habe die nächsten stunden einfach nur
immer wieder dieselben sachen geklickt
und gewartet das war wirklich richtig
langweilig ich bin jetzt eine stunde
drinnen ich habe eine stunde podcast
gehört und mich genau an dieser
anleitung erhalten am anfang sei es ein
bisschen kritisch aus und wir sind
irgendwie bis zu 50 euro runter und
jetzt bin ich tatsächlich 70 euro im
plus auf der einen seite sind natürlich
mega geil weil ich 70 euro in einer
stunde verdient habt davon bin ich auf
youtube meilenweit entfernt auf der
anderen seite ist aber unendlich scheiße
weil ich eben genau das nicht zeigen
wollte also ich bin eigentlich davon
ausgegangen dass ich jetzt geld verzockt
weil ich überhaupt keine ahnung von
blackjack habe habe ich mir dann die
mathematischen statistiken zu black jack
enten rausgesucht das bedeutet wenn ich
eine 8 und einer 7 hatte und der dealer
eine queen wurde mir genau angezeigt was
ich tun soll und dass für jede einzelne
mögliche hand dass so ein riesiges
register und da habe ich mich 100
prozent daran gehalten und dann eben
angefangen black jack zu spielen und
auch hier lief es nicht anders als im
roulette es war zwar nicht super
aufregend aber es hat tatsächlich
funktioniert und ich habe mich stück für
stück weiter hoch arbeiten können
was man aber nicht vergessen darf ich
habe eine sicherheit von fast 1000 euro
eingezahlt um 1 euro einzusetzen also
der maximale gewinnen den ich erzielen
konnte war ein euro für 1000 euro
sicherheit das ist ein verhältnis
jenseits von gut und böse aber es hat
leider funktioniert und genau jetzt
wird's gefährlich ist 19.50 mittlerweile
ich bin seit vier stunden oder so auf
dieser online casino seite und es läuft
blendend ich habe jetzt noch mal 80 euro
mit blackjack verdient und genau jetzt
wäre der zeitpunkt wo man aufhören
müsste weil es hat gut funktioniert und
jetzt wird man übermütig und will mehr
einsatz machen ich habe gerade wirklich
so eine minute inne gehalten im reallife
würde ich jetzt rausgehen wir machen das
aber jetzt fürs video wir haben jetzt
ein bisschen spielgeld deswegen gehe ich
jetzt auf fünf euro pro spiel und schaue
was dabei passiert und es ist genau
gekommen wie es kommen musste ich habe
eine hand mit fünf euro gespielt ist
funktioniert nicht ich muss die einsätze
verdoppeln in der strategie immer wenn
ich verliere und jetzt spiele ich eine
80 euro blackjack hand es ist so dumm es
ist so ok es ist wirklich schrecklich
auch das mit den fünf euro hat nach
anfänglichen startschwierigkeiten jetzt
doch funktioniert ich habe jetzt
innerhalb von 15 minuten noch mal 80
euro mehr gemacht also wir sind jetzt
200 euro im plus
das macht einen stundenlohn von 50 euro
bisher
es ist wirklich die größte scheiße und
das ist komplett saß aber ich bin 349
euro ein paar cent im plus
vor allem die black jack strategie hat
sich extrem gut bewährt und das
funktioniert die ganze zeit am laufenden
band und ich gehe immer ein paar euro
runter und dann aber wieder ein bisschen
mehr hochgeht aber jetzt wirklich das
gefühl dass ich viel viel viel zu tief
drin bin ich denke an gar nichts anderes
mehr und guckt die ganze zeit gemacht
die ganze zeit hier weiter ich lass gut
sein für heute und morgen weiter und
dann mal schauen entweder wir verlieren
alles oder das geht so weiter ich will
nicht hoffen für dieses video aber für
meinen bank account wäre das schon ganz
okay okay ihr habt gehört ich beende tag
1 mit 349 euro im plus und ich verlasse
das büro nicht mit supertollen
gefühlen sondern mit sehr gemischten
gefühlen ich wollte ein video machen
indem ich zeige dass es keine
möglichkeit gibt das casino
auszutricksen und dass das der grund ist
warum man niemals anfangen sollte egal
welche art zu spielen und das problem
ist das fällt schwer das dann zu
argumentieren wenn es bei einem
scheinbar in dem moment dann doch
funktioniert also egal wie das jetzt
hier ausgeht ob ich gewinne oder ob ich
groß verlieren
es ist keine option sein geld zu machen
indem man casino spielt es gibt diese
option nicht im casino verliert man auf
lange sicht sein geld jedes mal sonst
gelb ist dieses konzept nicht bitte
versteht das und bitte versteht auch
dass ich nichts anderes zeigen möchte
kein zweites experiment es ist es
möglich mit mathematik das casino immer
zu besiegen auch am zweiten tag ändert
sich nichts ich spiele genauso weiter
wie ich angefangen habe black jack mit
fünf euro einsatz nach statistiken und
dem materialsystemen ich halte mich 100
prozent daran wurden spiele circa vier
stunden der zweite tag ist beendet ich
habe mir ein limit gesetzt wenn ich mein
geld verdoppeln würde oder ich eben bei
null wäre würde ich aufhören das ist
jetzt der fall
ich habe mein geld mehr als verdoppelt
tatsächlich ist es am ende nochmal
richtig kritisch geworden und ich musste
320 euro setzen um einen verlust wieder
gut zu machen
tatsächlich hatte ich dann dabei enormes
glück und habe direkt einen blackjack
bekommen was bedeutet man bekommt den
zweieinhalbfachen betrag ausgezahlt
dadurch habe ich auch deutlich mehr als
das doppelte verdient wir haben
angefangen mit roulette dann
weitergemacht mit blackjack und jetzt
haben wir tatsächlich 1593 euro und 96
cent auf dem konto
das macht bei einem einsatz von 755 euro
883 euro
und 96 cent reingewinn das ist wirklich
unglaublich wir haben mehrmals
situationen wo wir ganz knapp davor
waren dass unsere sicherheit nicht
gereicht hätte um das nächste mal quasi
unser negatives spiel auszubaden es hat
aber alles funktioniert meine nerven
sind am ende ich will mich gar nicht
weiter damit beschäftigen ich zahle das
sofort auf und schon alles raus ich will
damit nichts zu tun haben
ich will zum abschluss aber noch mal
sagen ich hätte langfristig verloren und
ihr würde das auch und genau das sagt
auch die statistik mit dem martin kahle
system zögert man den verlust einfach
nur weiter raus und irgendwann knallt
richtig und man verliert viel mehr als
man am anfang eingesetzt hat dass genau
das gefährliche an der strategie ich
hatte jetzt einfach glück und es hat
funktioniert bitte fangen nicht an zu
spielen wenn ihr schon am spielen seit
schaut in die video beschreibung der
findet ihren link und da könnt ihr hilfe
bekommen ich werde jetzt in der ich
werde jetzt erst mal keine videos mehr
zum thema glücksspiel machen das hat bei
mir jetzt einfach zu gut immer
funktioniert als dass ich das bild vom
glücksspiel zeichnen kann was ich
eigentlich gerne zeichnen würde
nichtsdestotrotz haben wir jetzt 800
euro mit dem wir in den nächsten videos
weiter machen können ich nehme den
kompletten gewinn und werde den in die
nächste video strecken also vergesst
nicht zu abonnieren
das video zu leiten und zu kommentieren
was ihr von dem ganzen thema haltet
macht es gut dass nächste woche